le retour de cette saison est
particulièrement attendue suite à
l'annulation vous le savez de l'année
dernière de la saison dernière on vous a
fait un récap de cette histoire et je
vous le dis on a une petite info à vous
donner sur koh lanta juste après regarde
bonne nouvelle pour les fans d' aventure
extrême de reset et de poteaux la
prochaine saison de koh lanta est en
pleine préparation et c'est denis
brogniart lui même qui l'a annoncé sur
les réseaux sociaux ça y est on a
commencé avant-hier le tournage de la
prochaine saison de koh lanta avec un
bon casting d'aventuriers les amis
prises de très loin ce matin sur lci
thierry moreau a livré les premières
informations sur cette nouvelle saison
le tournage a lieu aux îles fidji la
production utilise des infrastructures
déjà financer certains candidats la
saison annulée
participent à cette nouvelle aventure et
enfin la date de diffusion sera prévu
pour mars 2019
vous rappelle la dernière saison avait
été avorté à cause d'un scandale qui
avait poussé la production a annulé le
tournage en urgence après seulement
quelques jours
à l'époque candide renard une candidate
de l'aventuré avait accusé est dit bio
de l'avoir agressé sexuellement une
affaire toujours pas résolue à ce jour
mais qui a coûté 11 millions d'euros à
la production
alors oui alors ils ont dit pas d'aplomb
n'a pas loin d'applaudir à sur koh lanta
et mais qu on les connaît pas on est sûr
de cinq étages alors c'est vrai que
c'est un scandale qui a éclaté voilà
seulement cinq jours après le tournage
moi je pense qu'il n'aurait pas dû voilà
arrêter le tournage il aurait dû
rapatrier les deux personnes voilà qui
était très belle choisi comme témoin les
non non non non on a tous alors sachez
le en justice on a toujours le droit et
on a toujours le choix
rachida dati mais je vous le dis non
mais moi je pense qu'ils auraient fait
ça ils auraient dû faire ça mais c'est
pas grave alors les candidats de la
saison annulée
donc on s'est revu leur aventure
s'arrête et me paraît voilà je vous dis
que ya des candidats qui vont des
anciens candidats qui vont participer
c'est simple gilles verdez voyez alors
ça crée un énorme scandale de mon point
de vue parce que la procédure je suis
pas d'accord avec vous l'affairé grave
la procédure et non mais je réduis juste
sortir les deux protagonistes
alors là il est la saison la procédure
est en cours et ils reprennent des
anciens alors que souvenez vous il avait
dit non il ya une telle pression de
certains que ils en reprennent sans
doute une au moins une candidate et moi
je trouve ça scandaleux parce que ça a
été annulé
ça n'aurait pas dû arriver il n'aurait
pas dû reprendre deux candidats pour le
faisant penser malik l'impression qu'il
va livrer des sushis et que c'est vrai